welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float the
official trailer for it chapter two has
just been released and the first glimpse
that the film has a lot to him back from
it there's a hell of a lot of hype
around this movie with YouTube even
advertising a trailer for the trailer so
the creative team are clearly very
confident with the movie throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the first
teaser as well as what could happen in
the film this is full spoilers ahead so
if you don't want to know anything about
the movie or what could happen going up
the source material and then I highly
recommend that you turn off now with
that out the way thank you for clicking
this video I hope you enjoy it
now let's get into my eighth chapter two
trailer breakdown like you remember
cleaner where you feel free to look
around well I get the water boil in your
hair is
[Music]
[Music]
there you go awesome music
I do apologize it gets so very hot here
this time of year it's time what do you
feel like you could just about die but
you know what they say about dairy hmm
no one who dies here ever really dies
but tell me how is it being back in
Derry it's got a strange strange oh my I
had some cookies in the oven before you
came stay right there
I shouldn't impose I'm gonna no I insist
we photos are lovely mr. Kirsch are
these your family my father came to this
country with 14 dollars in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus
I was always daddy's little girl what
about you are you still his little girl
Beverly are you
it's me the losers Club has officially
begun
[Music]
I was gonna do this but you have to
stick together
[Music]
[Music]
from the first look at the trailer it's
pretty safe to say that this is sticking
very close to the source material with
the losers Club returning 27 years later
to take down Pennywise the clown since
they're packed in the first film they've
all went their separate ways and the
film will clearly not only tackle the
danger that Pennywise presents but also
have friendships fracture over the airs
with many of the characters not wishing
to return to what could be their death
Mike now works as a librarian in Derry
bill has become a best-selling horror
novelist ben is an architect beverly is
a fashion designer and Ricci as a
late-night television comedian and he
still lives with his mother and runs a
limo service and Stan is a real estate
broker they've all went on to lead happy
lives as Pennywise promised except maybe
Eddie however that doesn't mean that the
ultra forgotten and it's pretty clear
that Mike will be the one that has to
bring them all together it's clear that
their childhood still haunts them with
Beverly returning to her home to reflect
on a past and finding her old note
however this isn't a happy place and
it's clear that Pennywise has been
waiting for her disguised as an old
woman to lure her into a sense of safety
from here the trailer escalates quickly
and the tone of it is absolutely
terrifying hats off to whoever cast this
old woman because she kills it around
the room are old pictures including one
of penny wise for those who don't know
the creature landed in Derry and used
this appearance to lure children to him
Pennywise is as old as the town itself
and he actually helped it to grow so
that he had a constant supply of food in
the book Pennywise is as much of the
town as the town is him and his image is
a nice callback from here we get clips
of the film with the losers club having
to return to the well in order to take
him down as the final shot shows he is
still hunting children and has a massive
effect over the landscape it's an
absolutely terrifying first look and I
love how they play it as a scene and if
the atmosphere continues like this then
we're in for a real treat now one of the
most notable things about the film is
that it will retain one of the strangest
elements of the book named the ritual of
tchard in the original movie this
involved the losers Club performing
jokes and other abstract things to ward
off Pennywise it's extremely surreal and
deals with many metaphysical concepts
but screen writer Gary Doberman has come
for
that it is indeed in the film when
discussing this in an interview with
cinema blend he stated the ritual of
tchard is challenging but it's such an
important component to the book that we
had to address it that stuff is
difficult to balance but because the
creative team worked with each other
before when I am writing pages and all
that stuff it becomes more of a
conversation and less like hey here's
what I did it's sort of organic it's
really just kind of chipping away at the
stone and trying to find the most
focused accessible way into some of the
more metaphysical aspects of that book
I think this scene has the potential to
either make or break the movie but
either way it's going to be interesting
to see how it plays out on screen and
actually hope we get a bit more of the
background of penny wise in this film
and stole the original tease there I
would really like to see a study on the
character in this movie penny wise of
course feasts off of fear and this is
why it's forced to go after children
though he's a shapeshifter the character
found that upon attempting to go after
adults he found it very difficult to
manifest as things that they tend to
worry about such as unpaid bills and
jobs this of course gives the losers
Club a huge advantage when facing him
now and I'd love to at least see some
lip service paid to the fact that he
finds it difficult scaring them when
he's not in penny wise form as that's
the main thing that they all fear now
what I do think the second part of the
book is weaker than the first
I hope it's reversed for this film with
it being massive moment for horror
movies to back that up we have a pretty
solid endorsement that comes in the form
of Stephen King who this week tweeted
looking forward to hit chapter 2 it
should be I've seen it and it's terrific
the trailer is coming Thursday at noon
your float
so that's pretty much as good of an
endorsement as you can get right well
King has been pretty critical of some of
his adaptations in the past whilst
praising others that weren't so good I
don't want to get too heavy into the
whole Stanley Kubrick argument but it's
pretty public that king did not like the
original shining movie and even went on
to make his own which yeah didn't do
well it's probably my favorite horror of
all time if not second to John
Carpenter's The Thing so I'm definitely
taking this recommendation with a pinch
of salt saying that though at least King
has been honest in the past when he's
hated a movie - this is something to at
least get excited over obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer so make sure
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
trailer breakdown of this week's other
big teasers spider-man Home Coming would
you be linked at the end
[Music]
you
[Music]